hey david how could republicans convince
young people to start voting for them
yeah so there's still this really big
imbalance
um in the 2020 u.s election presidential
60 of voters 18 to 29 voted for joe
biden
60 only 36 voted for donald trump
i think a lot of this is sort of a
culture war issue related and i'll
explain it to you
in this way um the republican party
historically has had
their sort of more religious and and
cultural issues
and then their policy platforms the
policy platform of low taxes and low
regulation
it's not really appealing to young
people and
that is not a draw for young people to
the republican party
when the country was more religious
stuff like being against
gay marriage and being against abortion
maybe did more to pull some young people
in
to the republican party but over time
we are seeing that even so-called
conservative young people tend to have
significantly more liberal views when it
comes to economic issues
than they did 15 or 20 years ago the
occupy wall street movement was a part
of that and other things have affected
that
they are increasingly less religious so
like gay marriage
abortion are not big issues for most
young people
so what does the republican have to
offer them
maybe the new culture war issues could
potentially work so
for example if somebody like madison
cawthorne a young republican elected
official from north carolina not south
carolina as i misstated last week
if madison cawthorne can get young
people really fixated on the new
cultural issues which include
you know de-platforming and free speech
and censorship
cancel culture and that
type of thing maybe that's a way that
the republican party could capture more
of the young vote
that's a possibility the problem as i
see it
is that the republican party on policy
doesn't really have much right now other
than
oppose democrats cut welfare programs
and cut taxes they are against the
affordable care act but they don't
really have a solution
and young people are probably aware that
if aca goes
if i'm under 26 i may not be able to
stay on my parents insurance so
there's no interesting policy ideas and
so as interesting as the idea of we're
gonna fight cancel culture and we're
going to fight against
policing of speech and de-platforming
and all this stuff
that might be interesting to some young
people and might pull them towards the
republican party
if they care at all about policy there's
going to be nothing there so
i think that unless there's a wholesale
change within the republican party
they're going to keep hemorrhaging young
voters now that being said
still given how ridiculous republican
policy has been towards anything that
young people would care about
it's shocking they still got 36 trump
trump still got
36 percent of the 18 to 29 vote
doing everything wrong they still got 36
percent of the vote so this is one of
those things where
on the one hand the republican party is
doing everything wrong to try to appeal
to young people and the things
i think could help them appeal to more
young people are not things they seem
interested in doing so that seems
terrible it spells disaster
but yet on the other hand they still got
36 percent of the 18 to 29
votes so only some small tweaks could
probably make them quite competitive or
at least closer to competitive
among that group give me your sense
of whether there's a way to maintain
something that is the modern republican
ideology
that would appeal to young people i'm
not really sure that there is
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers
and you can use it on all of your
devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week for just 99 cents
and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman